a case that you cite in your lawsuit
called Pernell versus Florida Board of
Governors of State University system uh
where you say you quote from that uh the
judges ruling there saying that it's not
acceptable to
impose uh the state to impose its own
Orthodoxy of viewpoint about the content
allowed within University classrooms and
of course the case that we're talking
about here is one part that fire is also
party to against uh the state of
Florida's uh law that has become known
as the stop woke act the individual
rights and Education Act I produced a
short documentary about that issue and
I'm going to play a quick clip from it
where Pernell the named plaintiff in the
case Professor Pernell uh speaks out
about his feelings uh about the stop
woke act and how it would affect what
he's doing in the classroom so that we
can see the flip side of that
conversation Cornell a law professor at
Florida A&M University or FAMU and
historically black college is a
plaintiff in the aclu's case challenging
that part of the law he's afraid that
the law will Outlaw discussions of
systemic racism which he says is part of
famu's institutional history the state
created the law school in 1949 to
accommodate two black law students
who applied to the racially segregated
University of Florida in 1966 the state
forced it to seize admitting new
students until then Florida Governor Jeb
Bush signed a law to reopen it in 2000
Pernell worries that if instructors were
to characterize that history as
systemically racist they'd run a foul of
the Law's restrictions around teaching
the concept I have no way of knowing
that my passion for teaching students
about history history about change and
about their ability to bring about
change I have no way of knowing that
that isn't offensive to these subjective
judges of what is endorsing what is not
endorsing what is promoting what is not
not promoting so I do now live with the
idea that at any moment the state can
come and take negative action against me
because of my thought let's say that
there was a blue state that did kind of
the opposite of this and they said we're
going to ban a professor who has a
different Viewpoint and thinks critical
race theory is wrong and that we should
be talking about color blindness as a
legitimate concept and things like this
anytime you put State and band together
danger all right why does the state ban
any
thought if we are in a free
society that exists and develops based
on free Exchange change of
ideas so Professor Pernell there is
taking a very principled stance he is in
he believes in uh systemic racism and
thinks critical race theory is an
important uh academic concept but he
does not would not be it sounds like he
would not be in favor of a law like the
California law that forces professors to
embrace or promulgate these Concepts I I
guess my question and this this could be
the last question for you Bill because I
know you have to leave so feel free to
jump off whenever you need to after this
but do you feel the same way in the
reverse Direction um that professors who
do believe in many of these Concepts
we've gone through in the Dei framework
should be free to teach those in the
classroom provided that their students
are free to disagree and not be graded
negatively um I would would support that
as long as it goes both ways but
frequently that is not the
case you know I support Professor
Cornell's freedom of speech in the
classroom to teach the material as he
sees fit but I also
support and would would make sure that
this is brought up in that discussion
that his students have the right to
disagree with him and lay out their case
and that's the whole whole point of
higher education anyway is is the free
exchange of ideas May the best idea win
and sometimes even though we're right
and we're
arguing for a particular position that
is is right our arguments may be weak
and we lose that particular argument so
you go back you regroup you redevelop
and come back again and that's that's
how it was when I went through college
and that's how it should
be the idea of May the best idea win I
think is so important and many of the
deia cheerleaders are in a sense uh
betraying a sense of like their own
insecurities um if you're attempting to
so rigidly impose this
Orthodoxy uh and mandating it from on
high at least to me that indicates a
certain sense of like o maybe they're
not so confident that these ideas would
win in the marketplace um because
they're not choosing to use those sort
of like classically liberal means of
duking it out it is instead a different
approach being tried right now and that
really raises my hackles at least where
I I sort of am like wait a second you
know is there an insecurity being
communicated there are they actually
confident that these ideas would win
yeah and you know uh Liz when I raised
that that phrase the marketplace of
ideas with Chris rufo in a previous live
live stream that we had he disagreed
that we even have a Marketplace of ideas
in higher education uh we're going to
drop links to all this media in the
description so uh you know you if you're
interested in this conversation you
might want to check out that full stream
with rufo but I want to play uh a clip
of what rufo's AR counterargument was in
that that debate or discussion with with
me and Nick Gillespie and then get you
to react to the argument that he's
making in favor of the stop woke act
Jesse because he was one of the
intellectual Architects behind it has
argued that it does have a say over
what's taught at taxpayer subsidized
schools teaching kids not that is not
the right uh clip uh let's
see uh I don't like you I guess I don't
support abolishing them but when they're
off track when they're not supporting
those values when they're not pursuing
those as the Telos or the highest
principle of the University it's up to
the voters to Institute reforms and what
we have is a situation where there is
not a there's a kind
of kind of written idea of academic
freedom but the actual on the ground
facts I've talked to a lot of professors
in the UF system uh that are
conservative that say I can't express my
opinion I can't do the research I want
if I say that I'm conservative I won't
get tenure
um uh my ideas are suppressed I'm forced
to go through these diversity trainings
this is a problem for people within the
the system it's also a problem for the
public to say hey wait a minute if
you're public if you're professorate if
you're faculty because of the hiring and
because of the funding and because of
the selection process is now in many
public universities 20 30 40 to one
dependent on the Departments between
progressives or liberals and
conservatives you have a massive
imbalance in faculty you have an
Administration that has adopted Dei as
the highest principle of the university
and they're forcing professors to to bow
down to left-wing diversity ideology
they're forcing professors to sign
diversity statements okay they're
forcing professors to be hired on the
basis of their commitment to these
ideologies you have a huge problem and
yet what I'm hearing is that well you
can't do anything about it because you
know government
bad how do you reply to that argument
rufo is making Jesse which is that these
are public institutions and
therefore the government through the
legislative process the the
democratically elected legislature they
should be able to shape the standards of
what is allowed to be taught on a
college
campus uh well first i' just say to
think
that uh an the answer to an insufficient
Marketplace place of ideas is to censor
part of the
marketplace is a very odd
response
uh as
for the taxpayer funded nature of
universities
uh taxpayers fund un universities
because they are knowledge generating
machines and they generate that
knowledge by bringing together a lot of
people a lot of ideas is to kind of duke
it out and hopefully from that
process we can discover some sort of
Truth gain some sort of knowledge uh
historically that has worked actually
quite well in the United States and
that's why we fund
universities uh taxpayer funding does
not mean that taxpayers get to tell
every government employee what they can
and can't say that's never how it's
worked and it's not how it works when it
comes to
universities the interest of taxpayers
and of the government in a university is
both the knowledge generating and the
education of adult college students
again we want to expose them to a
variety of ideas and that is very very
different from say uh what you see in
the K through 12 environment where
your where the Public's interest is more
inculcating Community Values in young
children in college you want to bring
together all sorts of ideas and expose
students to all of
them yeah you know Li Liz talked earlier
a little bit about the I think she said
tight rope that you are walking at fire
where you are willing to take on both of
these cases it's vanishingly rare that I
mean I feel like it's maybe uh us and
and fire at this point that that are
willing to that civil liberties oriented
organization that I've heard so much
about but I'm not
sure there used to be another onea
Glasser one that was sides but but I
mean maybe that maybe that plays into
why fire has Rebrand you know you
started as the foundation for indivi
individual rights in education and now
uh you have expanded that beyond the
educational sphere I mean is there any
insight that you can give us there as to
you know why has fire uh expanded its
Mission um is it because of that that
lack of people willing to to walk that
tight
rope I think um there was definitely a
need
for an organization to come out and be
willing to defend Free Speech just
because it's free speech and not on the
grounds of
the uh correctness of the opinion being
given uh and I know that fire first
before it ever wanted to expand it
wanted to make sure that it was doing
everything it could in the higher
education space and so it grew enough to
kind of um perfect its craft there and
then it became time where
um they could jump
into the wider uh community and it also
uh happen to coincide with um a lot of
the negative trends that we've seen in
higher education as students graduate
are kind of coming out into the broader
world and uh it's a good time for fire
to expand and counter that outside of
the University system as well yeah this
is also interesting to me because I feel
like I um got a very early Taste of this
I entered College in 2014 and left
College in 2016 but it was interesting
because I think so many people when
attempting to trace um this sort of
second wave of political correctness on
campus obviously we had the wave in the
90s which I know Greg lukan off of fire
has actually written about um
wonderfully for reason uh for our print
magazine of like hey actually this wave
of political correctness on campus this
isn't really the first time this has
happened this has been a little bit of a
cyclical thing throughout um you know
recent American history but I do think
that this most recent wave is really
traced back to starting around Ferguson
Missouri 2014 um that whole thing and
and it was really interesting to arrive
on campus right as so much of this was
bubbling up
um but then I see so much of my cohort I
mean I got the hell out of college and
early in part because of this and so
much of my cohort it's been so
interesting watching them then go into
you know major newsrooms and other
different Industries and it's
fascinating how these ideas that I think
were either you know inculcated at the
University level or not pushed back on
sufficiently at the University level you
know Circa 2015 2016 2017 have really
now
flowered into something else and taken
root in all kinds of other Industries I
reported a piece for our friend Mike
salana of pirate wires a few maybe a
year and a half ago that talked a little
bit about uh the Dei efforts uh at tech
companies and the sort of like dihr
convergence and how for many Tech
employees um you know it's it's many of
the same objections that we're lodging
here um and that that Professor blankin
has has commented on here where it's a
little bit of like well wait a second
doesn't this distract from the actual
thing we were hired to do doesn't this
distract um you know in the professor's
case from educating students from
teaching them chemistry or in the tech
employee case uh from sales goals uh or
you know creating the best possible
software to sell to their customers so I
think there's there's something that
people are sort of slowly coming around
to which is like a lot of these things
distract people who actually want to um
roll up their sleeves and get hard work
done and there's also a certain Hollow
that I think people people are sort of
slowly becoming wise to um and you know
at the same time this also then breeds
an entire industry of what I view as
grifters like the Chris rufos of the
world who are really converting a lot of
this um craziness into their own sort of
culture war and um mandating another
form of viewpoint homogeneity which I'm
not super keen on so you know all props
to fire for fighting the good fight and
for the professors uh who are willing to
stick their necks out and possibly take
an unpopular position uh in pursuit of
more academic freedom uh thank you guys
so much for talking to us yeah and uh
the issue with the the mandating aspect
that's the key word uh Liz that you
mentioned there is that you know we can
sit here and have our criticisms of
these Concepts and I think they're
warranted and you know even when they're
not mandated I think there's a lot of uh
uh
self-destructive ideas that we've gone
over today that that should be
vigorously criticized but it is a the
the reason we Advocate a marketpl of
ideas is because this stuff is really
complicated and reducing it to its you
know woke versus non-woke and this all
has this all is Gospel or this all is
garbage it doesn't really make sense it
has to kind of play out in a messy
social process and and the less we have
uh you know government or uh Community
College state connected Community
College review boards uh trying to
impose their vision of the social good
the more we can actually I think uh
progress and get to an actual social
good hey thanks for watching that clip
from our conversation with Jesse applebe
of fire and Professor bill blankin from
Reedley College for the full
conversation click here for another clip
go here